[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
this is going to be a tough climb for
her opening statements soon begin in the
highly anticipated trial of elizabeth
holmes what prosecutors will have to
prove in order to convict the former
theron ceo plus the latest update in the
murdoch murder cases out of south
carolina months after the deaths of his
wife and son alex murda now says he was
targeted too and as the supreme court
upholds the texas law prohibiting nearly
all abortions high-profile companies are
backing pro-choice texans with legal
support and donations the defendant
intended to kill
susan berman after weeks in the
courtroom both sides have now rested in
the trial of robert durst hear more
gripping testimony ahead of closing
arguments law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin opening statements begin this
week in the trial of elizabeth holmes
the founder of the blood testing company
accused of defrauding investors
companies and patients law and crimes
anjanet levy is here with what to expect
from this long-anticipated trial brian
elizabeth holmes and her company
theranos were the toast of silicon
valley until her claims about what her
blood testing could do
began to unravel
what do you dream for
that less people have to say goodbye too
soon to people they love that was
elizabeth holmes years ago explaining
what she believed her blood testing
technology could do
her company theranos was once valued at
9 billion
with the family of betsy devos new
england's patriots owner robert kraft
and rupert murdoch investing but
prosecutors say theranose was a scam and
holmes faces federal wire fraud charges
accused of defrauding investors law and
crimes adam classfeld has followed the
case
she is being charged federally and
most often federal prosecutors do not
lose if you look at the statistics it's
very well upwards of 90 percent and
conviction rate but prosecutors will
have to prove holmes willfully defrauded
investors knowing the testing technology
and her edison testing machine were
bogus holmes was a 19 year old stanford
university dropout when she founded
theranos
you all are part of something that is
going to change our world what higher
purpose is there
she's been described as charming and
garnered a lot of media attention
i think that definitely her defense
attorneys want to play up the fact that
this has gotten an exceptional amount of
media to coverage that she
had this reputation as the youngest
female self-made billionaire uh that
it all came crashing down with the wall
street journal expose bad blood and
became a documentary holmes is expected
to argue in part that she was misled
about the company and technology by her
then boyfriend ramesh sunny balwani who
she now claims abused her physically and
sexually balwani has denied the claims
in legal documents
we're going to see new dimensions of her
defense of her arguments and of the case
at as a whole
this trial is taking place in federal
court so unfortunately cameras and audio
streams are not allowed but we'll still
keep you up to date on what happens
meanwhile sonny balwani's trial is
scheduled to begin next year brian
thanks angeannette joining us today is
defense attorney matt mangino and terry
austin matt typically speculations about
who the defendant is dating now what
house they are living in during the
trial would not come in at trial but
where holmes is accusing her ex and
co-defendant of abuse that contributed
to these crimes are these now fair game
i think everything is on the table once
you uh begin to present a defense that
uh
part of your actions in this uh case uh
were the result of being battered of
being sexually abused uh you know i
think it's fair game then to come back
uh as a prosecutor and say well hey you
kind of rebounded uh from your um bad
relationship and now you um have a child
you have a new boyfriend and you're
living in a palatial uh estate while
this trial is uh pending
yeah it's gonna be interesting to see
how that plays into effect of this
entire case her whole life is gonna be
under a microscope where elizabeth
holmes came out and said this technology
was basically gonna change the world
terry a local jury has been selected do
you think people from the silicon valley
will be sympathetic to a defense that
holmes was faking it until she made it
something common in the tech world or
could that backfire
it could backfire i think jurors
understand that silicon valley startups
often walk this thin line between
exaggeration and deception and the real
question is whether or not holmes
intentionally tried to deceive them i've
been following this case from the very
beginning and she repeatedly claimed
that these machines were able to
diagnose blood
diagnosed blood issues and conditions
just from a small prick and a couple of
drops of blood but employees were trying
to say to her that the machines were
inconclusive that they weren't working
that they weren't reliable and she
continued to ignore them so some of them
actually even left their jobs because
they thought they were being ignored so
it's going to come down to what she knew
and when did she know it she could
potentially face 20 years in prison as
well absolutely and janet holmes trial
has been delayed because of the pandemic
but there was another reason for the
delay too right
elizabeth holmes actually became a mom
in july she gave birth to a little boy
a baby boy rather and you know that
caused a fourth delay in the trial on
top of those covid19 pandemic related
delays so it's not clear how the jury
will perceive her being a new mom is
that going to have an impact on how they
perceive her or view her or the evidence
we'll just have to wait and see but
she is a new mom to an infant
yeah and my understanding there will be
time allotted for her during the trial
to step out and go and nurse many people
speculating that maybe she did this
intentionally to garner sympathy from
the jury because of course a jury will
think about whether or not they're going
to send someone to jail with a newborn
but of course we will see how that all
plays out thank you everyone still ahead
on law and crime daily the south
carolina attorney shot in the head
surviving months after his wife and son
were shot dead on their family property
plus days before sentencing in the
deadly hit and run south dakota's
attorney general is stopped for speeding
the new body cam video next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury bonus
[Music]
welcome back we turn to south carolina
for the murder mystery of a mother and
son shot dead now the father says he too
was shot in the head
alex murdoch called police on saturday
saying he had been shot while changing a
flat tire murdo is a member of the
prominent south carolina legal family in
june myrtle called 9-1-1 to report
finding the bodies of his wife maggie
and their son paul shot dead near dog
kennels on the family's hunting property
the spotlight quickly turned to son paul
he was indicted in a boat crash that
killed 19 year old mallory beach after
paul's death investigators also looked
into the 2015 death of a teenager now
alex murdoch is recovering saying in a
statement on monday the murders of my
wife and son have caused an incredibly
difficult time in my life i've made a
lot of decisions that i truly regret i
am resigning from my law firm and
entering rehab after a long battle that
has been exacerbated by these murders
hours after that statement the law firm
responded saying his resignation came
after discovery that alex
misappropriated funds a forensic
accounting firm will be retained to
conduct a thorough investigation law
enforcement and the south carolina bar
have been notified the firm was founded
a hundred years ago by randolph murdoch
he along with alex's grandfather and
great grandfather all served as the top
prosecutor of four counties in lower
south carolina
let's bring back defense attorney matt
mangino and co-host terry austin terry
unfortunately prosecutors and their
families can be a target of a lot of
people's hate and the murders have been
prosecutors in the area for decades do
you think alex murdoch's shooting is
isolated or connected to something
bigger
brian i think that there are no
coincidences in this world and you just
have too many successive things going on
first the wife and son are shot dead
then he has a superficial gunshot wound
to the head
then he is misappropriating his law
firm's funds and then he says he made
bad decisions and he's checking into a
rehabilitation center so either there is
this huge conspiracy against him or
he could even be implicated in all of
these crimes i think ballistics at the
end of the day is going to show us what
happened and where these guns came from
so i think that's going to be very
important yeah it'll be very interesting
to see the trajectory of that bullet and
how that comes up matt this all comes on
the heels of accusations of
misappropriating funds at murdoch's firm
what do you make of the allegations and
murdoch's cryptic message about leaving
the firm
well you you can you can speculate that
um this is something to do with a
client's trust fund lawyers have trust
funds in which they put clients money
into hold typically when you talk about
embezzlement or misappropriation you're
talking about a trust fund where you're
holding clients funds and then you use
those funds as your own that's uh you
know a fundamental uh
issue with regard to lawyers and their
professional responsibility it
ultimately leads uh normally to some
sort of discipline whether it's
suspension or disbarment uh so it's a
very serious matter to uh use crime
finance funds as your own absolute a lot
of investigations surrounding the
murdoch family we've got death
misappropriation of funds but of course
when we get the information we'll be
sure to present it to you our viewers
here at the law on crime daily turning
now to new video into our newsroom of
south dakota attorney general jason
roundsburg at a traffic stop just days
before his sentencing related to last
summer's deadly hit and run officers say
he was speeding in a residential area
and wasn't carrying any identification
that was the reason i stopped doing 57
and a 35. south dakota's attorney
general jason roundsburg was stopped for
speeding in late august he did not have
his license on him and made no mention
of his name or position this is all i
needed
came and yeah a bulb quick at the store
and i thought i might as well run and
get the recyclables
this citation was roundsburg's seventh
speeding ticket since 2014 and came
shortly before he was supposed to appear
in court
you are receiving a citation today for
your speed like i said i had you at 57
in the 35.
up here's where we were at here's your
information
here's the violation itself it'll be
177.50
days later roundsburg pled no contest to
two misdemeanor charges for a fatal hit
and run in which the attorney general
struck and killed joe bieber while he
was driving home from a fundraiser in
september 2020. he was found guilty of
improper lane change and using a mobile
device while driving he was also charged
with one count of careless driving
rosberg received no jail time for the
incident but was fined 500 for each
misdemeanor count
coming up on law and crime daily a
contentious supreme court shutdown means
most abortions are illegal in the state
of texas how major rideshare companies
are pushing back in support of the
pro-choice movement plus after weeks of
back and forth both sides have now
rested in the lengthy trial of real
estate air robert durst what you need to
know ahead of tuesday's closing
statements
[Music]
now we go to california where both sides
have rested in robert durst's murder
trial
robert durst is on trial for the murder
of his best friend susan berman who was
found with a bullet wound in her head in
her benedict canyon home back in 2000.
the real estate air previously denied
ever writing the infamous cadaver note
but later confessed that he did send the
note to hopefully lead police officers
to berman's body before admitting to the
note he told the jinx documentary
director andrew jarecki that whoever
wrote the cadaver note must have been
the person that killed berman after
sending the letter robert durst left the
area making the eight-hour drive from
los angeles to san francisco and bought
a plane ticket to new york
i
decided that i wanted to get far away
from los angeles
i decided to go to san francisco
i drove to a
terminal
i i might have turned the car off
i might have left it running
i took my bag
that i
to have taken with me
to los angeles
i got out of the suv
and lifted it after the terminal
and went to the first gate
eight that i came to
and bought a ticket to new york
both sides rested last week and closing
arguments are set to begin on wednesday
before adjourning judge mark windham
gave the jury special instructions
reminding them what the state had to
prove for a special circumstance murder
the defendant is charged with a special
circumstance
of murder of a witness
to prove that this special circumstance
is true the people must prove that one
the defendant intended to kill
susan berman
two
susan berman was a witness to a crime
three the killing was not committed
during the commission of the crime to
which susan berman was a witness and
four
the defendant intended that susan berman
be killed to prevent her from testifying
in a criminal proceeding
for this special circumstance allegation
to be true
the defendant must believe the victim
will be a witness in a criminal
prosecution
when we come back the latest in the
arson trial of stanley ford out of
arkham ohio
we hear from the cases fire investigator
who breaks down what happened in the
victims last moments
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily we
turn now to ohio where stanley ford is
on trial for setting three fires that
killed nine people
stanley ford is accused of setting two
homes in one vehicle on fire the two
house fires resulted in nine deaths
including an entire family if convicted
ford could face a death penalty the
first home belonged to gloria gene hart
and lindell lewis neighbors testified
that ford had previous issues with lewis
before court adjourned for the long
weekend fire investigator brian peterman
took the stand to talk about his
observations when investigating the home
and ultimately did you make an opinion
as to whether this was an accidental or
intentionally set fire yes i did all
right
what was that opinion that it was an
incendiary fire that was an
intentionally set fire and where would
the origin have been the origin would
have been on the front porch of the
house which
on the west side okay
and that opinion that you're giving here
today is that within a reasonable degree
of scientific certainty yes
we also heard from chief medical
examiner dr lisa kohler who determined
that besides inhaling all of the smoke
gloria jean heart was perfectly healthy
when she died
so basically aside from
the smoke inhalation
her body was pretty healthy
a diet from the burns or they didn't die
from the burns in this case correct
correct this in this situation they are
dying from inhaling all of the smoke and
having a high level of carbon monoxide
in their system all right and for you as
a doctor
how do you how do you determine how do
you see that
well we will see the soot lining the
airways because we're taking out the
throat organs and taking out the lungs
and we can see the black soot deep down
into the airways
turning now to fall out from the supreme
court's decision to uphold the texas
abortion law it's one of the most
contentious abortion
rulings since the 1973's historic roe v
wade case
back in may texas governor greg abbott
signed the bill into law stating any
fetus with an audible heartbeat cannot
be aborted in most cases that means any
pregnancy passing the six week mark is
ineligible for abortion regardless of
whether rape sexual abuse or incest
played a role in the conception the law
also allows individuals to sue doctors
or abortion clinics suspected of
performing abortions after the six-week
mark just last week the united states
supreme court refused to block the law
upholding the original law following the
supreme court's decision u.s attorney
general merrick garland issued a
statement on labor day saying in part
quote while the justice department
urgently explores all options to
challenge texas sb-8 in order to protect
the constitutional rights of women and
other persons including access to
abortion we will continue to protect
those seeking to obtain or provide
reproductive health services pursuant to
our criminal and civil enforcement of
the face act under the 1994 face act
physical force or the threat of force is
prohibited against those seeking to use
or providing reproductive health care
meantime a bright spot for the
pro-choice texans as the rideshare
companies lyft and uber pledged to pay
the legal fees of drivers who would be
sued under texas's law the law states
anyone who aids or beds a restricted
abortion may face civil action in an
email from lyft the company pledges to
cover 100 of drivers legal fees and
donate 1 million dollars to planned
parenthood
all right let's break down some of these
potential arguments that our very own
aaron keller actually wrote about on
lawncrime.com uh matt what do you make
of the argument that if a person files a
claim based on the texas anti-abortion
law that they are in essence a private
attorney general and defendants may have
a civil rights claim against them
right brian they're acting under color
of law this statute was enacted uh for
the specific purpose of trying to
intimidate people who might help in some
way
provide services for someone who's
seeking an abortion i think it's fitting
that you use the 1983
civil rights statute which was created
back after the civil war to curb the ku
klux klans efforts to intimidate people
exercising their right to vote uh now
it's going to be used to to eliminate
people from intimidating uh women who uh
have a right to make decisions about
their own body their own reproductive uh
questions and issues uh to be resolved
so so it's very interesting and fitting
that 1983 uh is something uh that that
the attorney guard attorney general
garland is talking about exactly now
terry that covers the civil angle but
are there any criminal repercussions for
people who may bring an action under the
new law or actually try to stop people
from getting abortions
well actually brian the united states
code actually provides for penalties if
you have two or more people who are
conspiring to either injure or to
prohibit people from actually exercising
their constitutional rights like the
right to get an abortion and the statute
carries penalties actually up to 10
years so it's a serious enforcement
action and you know it could get even
more years if there is kidnapping
involved or attempted murder and you
have to think about the situations that
might start with this new law they might
get very volatile you might have people
shouting at each other if you have
demonstrations and i could very well see
the possibility that it could result in
some injury so you could have the civil
criminal penalty and you know you can
have the criminal penalty so i think
there's a lot of penalties involved yeah
it's gonna be interesting to see how
this plays out over the coming years
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you